[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: In
previous videos, you've
seen me running Python
code live on screen
and showing the results.
On this episode of
"AI Adventures,"
I'll show you how to use
Jupyter notebooks to achieve
the same results.
The way I've been running
Python code live on screen
is by using a Python
package called Jupyter.
Jupyter is built on
the IPython project
and allows for
interactive Python
to be run right in your browser.
But it is so much
more than that.
From bash commands, to
special magics, and plugins,
Jupyter enhances the Python
coding experience greatly.
If you're already
using Jupyter, I
hope I can improve your workflow
and show you some new tricks.
And if you're not using Jupyter
yet, what are you waiting for?
The easiest way
to install Jupyter
is by running pip
install jupyter.
Though, if you use
a packaged Python
distribution, such as Anaconda,
you may already have it
installed.
So be sure to activate your
Python environment first.
And let's dive in.
When running Jupyter
locally, you'll
connect to a locally-running
web server through your browser,
typically on port 8888.
Start your notebook by
running Jupyter notebook
in your working directory.
And usually, Jupyter will
just automatically open
in your browser
once it starts up.
But if not, point your browser
over to localhost 8888.
And if you don't already have a
notebook that you want to open,
you can create one
by clicking on New
and selecting Python
2 or Python 3,
depending on which
version of Python
you have running in
your environment.
Jupyter is quite flexible
and can handle many languages
and file types.
Though, we'll just stick
with Python for now.
Once you have a new
notebook running,
you can write some Python
code in the empty cell.
And just hit
Control-Enter to run it.
We can also run all our
typical Python code here,
just like you might
write in a Python script.
The difference is that
we can run it and see
the results right away.
Notice what happens when we
run a cell with Control-Enter.
The brackets on the
left side of the cell
shows an asterisk when a cell
is running or queued to run,
and then shows a number
once it's finished,
representing the order in which
cells were run during a given
session starting at 1.
The results of the final
line of a code cell
will be printed as an
output of that cell
but only if the value is
not stored to a variable.
So for example, if I import
TensorFlow and then concatenate
its version with a string, the
output is shown below the cell,
even though I didn't
use the Print command.
And of course, you can
And it would work
fine just as well.
Now, this is all very useful
for tinkering and seeing
how something behaves.
Another fantastic feature
of Jupyter notebooks
is the ability to show the
docstring of a function
that you are calling by
just pressing Shift-Tab.
This allows you
to call a function
with the correct
arguments without needing
to look up the
full documentation
every single time.
This feature also works with
your local custom functions.
So if you write good
docstrings, you'll be rewarded.
When you have a
lot of output, you
can reduce the amount
of space it takes up
by clicking on the left-hand
panel of the output, which
turns it into a
scrolling window.
If you double click, the output
will be collapsed entirely.
One cell is useful.
But really, we want
to have many cells.
To add a cell, click the
plus icon in the toolbar.
There are also some
cell execution commands
which can lead to new
cells being created for us.
If you press Shift-Enter,
it will run the current cell
and then just highlight
that next cell.
But if there is
no new next cell,
then a new cell is created.
On the other hand, if you
want to insert a new cell
immediately after
a given cell, you
can use Alt-Enter
to execute the cell
and then insert a new
cell directly after.
Perhaps the biggest feature
that I've left out so far
is the markdown support.
My first impression
of Jupyter notebooks
was its ability to
provide a great way
to both write code and describe
the code I was writing.
The rich semantics
of markdown allow
for researchers and educators
alike to easily and cleanly
communicate thoughts and ideas.
But perhaps, most
importantly, it
allows past you
to tell future you
what a given code
cell was supposed
to do in a way that can be
much more expressive than using
comment blocks.
Sometimes I just want to do
a quick check on how long
one training or evaluation
cycle is taking to execute.
For an easy way
to time your code,
start a cell with
percent percent time.
And once the cell
finishes executing,
it will print out how long
it took to run that cell.
It's not precision
atomic timing,
but it is a great way to get
some solid first impressions
with very minimal effort.
If you want to run a command
line command in your notebook,
the easiest way is to
put an exclamation point
in front of the command.
Now, this is only really
useful for one-off commands.
If you want to run
a bunch of commands,
start a cell with
percent percent bash
to cause the entire cell to be
interpreted as a bash script.
A great use of this feature
is to kick off TensorBoard.
Typically, running
TensorBoard might
involve starting a
new terminal window
and running it on the
command line, which
is what we would
typically do if we wanted
it to run for a long time.
But if we just want to
spin it up, take a peek,
and close it back down, having
it in a Jupyter notebook cell
isn't such a bad idea.
Plus, you'll never
forget to run it,
since it's embedded in your
workflow of notebook cells.
Notice that it will
occupy your notebook.
See that asterisk?
So you won't be able
to run anything else
while TensorBoard is running.
To stop it, click
Interrupt Kernel.
The asterisk will go away.
And you'll get
back control flow.
So there you have it, some of
my favorite Jupyter features
and capabilities.
This is, of course, not a
comprehensive discussion
of all of Jupyter's features.
I've just covered
some of my favorite
and most frequently used here.
There are many, many more
waiting for you to explore.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
right when they come out.
But for now, try out
Jupyter notebooks and all
that they have to offer.